all right cereal yes cereal oh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
um I grew up in New Orleans Louisiana
um also Baton Rouge Louisiana uh moved
there when I was 15 but
both what was your family like
um well
when I was born
the home I came
to
was completely different than the home
that I ended up
uh stepping out of
um but in the beginning it was a
it was really normal
really normal uh
you know loving family
my dad my dad was a barber he worked a
lot my mom
who's a stay-at-home mom uh
everything was everything was um
pretty normal they signed me up for a
gymnastics when I was like three or four
and uh
and I excelled in that
um I had a little sister
um we're four years apart
um
and
basically basically my life
in the beginning revolved around
gymnastics and spending time with my
little sister and my mom at home you
know and uh
and then um
when I was about 15
uh I had an opportunity to start a
program
um
with
a gymnastics
coach that uh would
wanted to coach me for uh Olympic
Training
and so
I did homeschooling in his gym
and um
and and trained and
but I only got to do that for about six
maybe eight months
and um
Hurricane Katrina that you know
devastated New Orleans
uh
hit and that's whenever
that's whenever my home life shifted and
it
it was like black and white you know it
was like
I went from
living in a home that
my parents valued like you know trust
and like
um
honesty and
you know and they were instilling some
pretty positive values in me and then
they both uh they both relapsed
on um
on their drugs of choice my dad
he did a he was a a heroin addict and a
crack addict my mom
periodically
um did methamphetamines but she also uh
her main thing was a pharmaceutical uh
benzos and uh alcohol
and
um my
mother who like I said I spent a lot of
a lot of my time growing up with
um
after after the hurricane she really
reclused a lot and uh
became really depressed and um
and uh extremely
um
extremely
just really not present
um she would sleep a lot and um
and but you because because she was at
home with me and my sister
you know she was she was the enforcer of
the rules in the in our house you know
so
I grew up like
not understanding how tough that job
could be and so I grew up like really
resenting her and my dad
as he got heavier in his drug use he
reclused in the way of work but he um
here
he got a name he
he had an anxiety problem
that um
that really uh
really wrecked his life
um and got worse through his drug use
and um he uh he couldn't he couldn't
even cut hair anymore because it was it
was so crippling you know he he didn't
it was like he didn't believe in himself
anymore he lost all of his like drive to
complete any goals and uh and
I feel like what that did
for me growing up
was
the positive values that they were
trying to instill in me in the beginning
turned into
a misguided belief systems that I
that I hammered into myself like every
day because
you know the when when there was one's
parenting now there wasn't and then you
know then then then they started
fighting and
um
my mom uh my mom started using meth uh
more and more as I got older
and uh
when I was 16
I caught her smoking uh I caught her
smoking a joint and she said
well
if you want to try some you can but
I just want you to know that
I think you should because
of your ADHD
and so you know naturally I I smoked and
I liked it and it it was it was it was
fun it was exciting it didn't really
help with my ADHD at all
um
it uh
it really caused um
it caused
what what became a ripple effect and and
uh in my life
as
as I as as the years went on like
my my mother would go through these
really short-lived phases where she
would want she would say I'm going to
get cleaned up and
what that meant was I had to get cleaned
up and
that was like taking my like
the only reprieve from
how like dysfunctional the house was
away from me
and
and
being
you know the the stubborn
the stubborn soul that I am
I I wasn't having it you know so
and as it went back and forth back and
forth back and forth you know you can
you can do whatever you want and then
all of a sudden like this militant like
no drugs no
um
you have to be home at a certain time
as opposed to like whenever she was on
drugs you know it was just back and
forth and it was really confusing and
so I I started acting out and
and then um I think whenever
and I stuck with just pot for a while
but whenever my mom
I walked in on her when I was 17 and she
was doing a shot of crystal
and
I believe in hindsight I believe she had
just pushed it
and was
was feeling the effects of it
and I remember when I walked in the room
the looks she gave me
it was it it it terrified me
and she
went off she she lost it she she was
livid
told me to get out of the room get out
of the [ __ ] room and
um
so I I you know I got out of the room
and
ran out of the house and went over to my
buddy's house and
didn't know what to make of it didn't
speak about it
I had um later on I found I I was
diagnosed with a PTSD from Hurricane
Katrina
it manifested itself in my sleep so I
didn't I didn't sleep very much and uh
and so
I remember a friend
another friend of mine his parents did
Crystal and I
knew that my mother I knew what was in
that shot
because I knew with the effect I I had
an idea of what the effects of Crystal
were
and
um
although like
the way she looked at me terrified me
the way that she reacted scared the hell
out of me
I knew that that was one more step into
not having to deal with
all of that all
all of that like I and I was really
aware of like
um wanting to run from the
emotions that I was feeling I was really
aware of that for some reason
um
I knew I didn't like how it felt but I
knew that I liked
I knew that I could deal with not
feeling
and that's exactly what uh you know
drugs
have done for me in the past and do for
me now and so
uh I was at that friends that particular
friend's house and
uh we stole some of the Chris some of
his uh appearance Crystal and
uh I did a shot
it was my it was a I I I I I
skipped smoking it and I did a shot and
foreign
I got that Rush from the shot
I felt like I felt like I could breathe
you know I felt like I felt like oh my
goodness
like
it felt like whatever was going on
at home or whatever like all I could
focus on at that moment was the way I
was feeling
and that that
allowed me to not think about anything
else and
it started
it started this downward
downward spiral
oh and
I had
ample amount of time to uh
to go on this drug Conquest that was
starting uh because you know after
Katrina after Katrina torment
life out of the frame
um we had relocated from New Orleans to
Baton Rouge Louisiana which is like an
hour and 10 minutes north and uh
and I was no longer doing gymnastics
um my grades had slipped to like
I was not applying myself at all in
school my behavior was like entirely out
of line
I was
starting to get violent with other
classmates teachers
and uh so by the time I was 17 I I had
already dropped out of school
and uh
and I was
full-time
full-time drugs and crime
you know that's what
that's just kind of like how things
progressed for me and
um
my um
I hadn't mentioned my dad for for a
second because my dad just he wasn't he
wasn't present ever he was always at
work and uh
and I remember
I remember whenever
they my parents divorced
which was when I was
19.
my mom
asked me
do you even realize
that
your dad hasn't been in your life
since
the storm hit
because
he wasn't there so he wasn't always on
my ass about all the
[ __ ] that I was doing you know
so naturally I would like
I I had like I took a liking to my dad
because he wasn't ever enforcing any of
the rules but when my mom
brought that up and pointed that out to
me it really made me put my dad under a
under a microscope and take a good look
at like
how
how much alike
him and I were
in the sense that
after that storm we had both given up on
everything that
that we dreamed and and and and lived
for you know him with with his uh would
be in a barber I mean that was his
passion and me with gymnastics
the and and that that made me really uh
resent my dad because you know
you know that saying the Apple doesn't
fall far from the tree well I felt like
I felt like all this I I was able I I
blamed all of it on my I shifted and
blamed everything that I was going
through on my dad
and uh which was easy because he wasn't
ever there and my mom was and she was
always in my ear
and um so
and again the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree the the crystal that I was
using the
the rush took care of everything that I
needed
the drugs to do but the high made me
anxious it made me like really really
anxious and that wasn't that wasn't
serving a purpose for me and so I tried
um
I tried heroin
for the first time when I was uh
when I was 19. and
um I was unaware that
when you do heroin
um
you
gain a habit and if you don't do it
anymore you don't you can't just quit
it's you get sick and I didn't realize
that and
I started I got sick for the first time
and I wasn't working I was
I was
I was working on being a
a grade A
loser you know and
um
and so
heroin costs money I didn't have a job
so I started burglarizing houses and
businesses and that that was a theme in
my life until
[Music]
um and and so I went to jail for it the
first time
got out
was on probation
and then
three months after they let me out I got
caught for another string of commercial
burglaries
and
that um that
[Music]
they convicted me of those and I went to
prison
and
in prison I had
I got I I was clean I I
um I started
I'd started um working in this uh
weightlifting program that they have in
the prisons in Louisiana and I um
I felt like I felt I I you know I was
I believe I was 22.
on my when my release date came up and I
was like I felt good I was
I had done a little bit of like
um like uh training on how to get a job
which I had never
I'd never even put any thought into up
until that point and I got out
and on parole and
got my first job
and
the whole time I'm there it was at Ace
Hardware
and
I had this like
this
this like itching this like um
it's really uncomfortable feeling when I
was around
any of my co-workers
um
when I was around any of the customers I
just I I
but the social anxiety of it
was like crippling and
so I started
I started drinking
and
you know at the time I was living in
Baton Rouge with with uh my parents
but I'd save up some money and decided I
was gonna move back to New Orleans and
I was drinking New Orleans you know New
Orleans is known for for The Nightlife
and uh it's it's also known for 24 7 365
days a year uh alcohol consumption and
and so I
I drank I drank a lot I drink a whole
lot and um
and because I had started working out in
prison uh I was also uh I and I was
totally obviously totally fine with
putting chemicals in my body uh I
started doing steroids and um I got a
new job but I got to back into New
Orleans and uh but that job
was uh I was a I I became a stripper
and
that's
that's whenever
my life
um
went completely out of control
I
no longer had
I know I felt I felt as if I no longer
was even in the driver's seat
of the choices I was making
and
um because of the choices I was making
led to me
uh
being raped
um
it led to
me being like
a solid 95 pounds soaking wet
no longer working and
anywhere because I was so skinny
uh lost the job stripping
after working there for like nine months
and
um
my heroin habit was out of control
oh and spice had just come out so
I I had been ordering uh spice chemical
this chemical for spice off of the dark
web and
uh I was
I was pumping out a ton of that
um and I had three gas stations that
were vending it for me and
and so I was living off of that which
was actually really good money because
that stuff
that stuff's just as
the use of it is just as habitual as
heroin
so the people who were buying it were
every day they were there every day to
buy it so I I had enough money to do as
much damage as I needed to
and then um
when they finally
stopped when they made all of the
chemicals for making spice illegal
um
I got arrested
I got arrested for
uh distribution and Manufacturing
and
um
went back to prison
and this time in prison
um well when I went when I went to
prison this time I
like I said I was 95 pounds
and whenever I kicked all the drugs
I had to be uh fed through a tube
because my insides had atrophied because
they had forgotten how to eat because I
wasn't eating
and uh so that was a it was a real tough
Lake
tough like
first two or three months locked up you
know and
um
so while I'm while but you know I did
get back get my health back and while I
was uh while I was locked up
I got a letter from a girl
that I had um
that that I that I knew whenever I was I
don't know 16 17 18 and
um she had contacted my mom
and asked where I was and so she started
writing me while I was locked up and so
anyway we started we started
conversating and one thing led to
another and
while I was locked up we started a
relationship and when I got out we
continued the relationship
we moved in together and uh left
Louisiana and moved to New Orleans moved
to Houston Texas
and uh
as soon as I got out of prison
full-time heroin addict
um
I
I gave
her
I'm responsible
for
making heroin available
for her to do for the first time
and uh
we so we were both we were both
full-time heroin addicts we moved to
Houston
she started stripping
I was basically living off of that and
burglaries
and um
we were we ended up getting engaged
and um
after we were together for
two years
um
we got into a fight one day and I left
the house to go get a drink
and on the way home
I stopped at the laundromat and we
washed our clothes at
and uh
just to cool off
and when I got back to the house
she was laying on the couch
completely gray
she was cold
and she was she died and
it was because
I used to make our shots
and
I had just picked up
before we started fighting
and I hadn't had a chance to make our
shots so while I was gone
she made her own shot and didn't know
how much to put in it and
so
she put too much and uh passed away and
I didn't come back
straight straight back from the store
like I like I was supposed to
and
for a long time
I um
I
I consider I I
foreign
I separated myself from
from society from from everybody
everybody everybody
because I felt like I felt like a
monster you know I felt like here's this
girl
who had all the opportunity in the world
and because she thought that I was
attractive or had
had some Charisma about me
she seeked me out and as a result
she loses her life
and
I had to
after that I put my I put myself I put
myself through the ringer you know like
my my drug habit I could no longer
um
pay rent uh hold a schedule
of of any sort like everything is
chaotic in my life and I became homeless
and um
and
it was just every single day
that I woke up
like everything was
losing its meaning like
um I I know I wasn't I was not I had no
relationship with my family anymore
I was uh
I was 100 of the time in self-loathing
and
I was a monster
self-proclaimed
and
I I'm pretty sure that I I'm pretty sure
that I wanted to die you know
um
and
tonight
so
I became homeless and
after I realized there was nothing for
me in Houston or in Louisiana anymore
I moved to um
Salt Lake City for a little while
homeless there
um in the downtown area
still doing my berry blurry thing you
know same old same old same old song
and um
and then
from there
I moved back down to Texas but to Dallas
this time
um
for a rehab
and
I didn't really have any
um
intentions on staying clean
I just
I think I just needed needed to clean up
get my health back maybe
is what that was about but I met a
therapist there and
uh this therapist like
didn't hone in on my drug use so much as
the belief system that I was a monster
because of
my
fiance's death
and
which I think which I think saved my
saved my life
because
through through work that I did with
that therapist
I was able to get a new
um concept on
the how and the why
things happen to people and
uh that everybody has
choices you know and
you know and I I don't like I I don't
let myself
get it get you know get excuses but
um
you know I
I guess I just
I grew to realize that
you know everybody has choices to make
and
she had hers and I had mine and
never once
did I encourage
her use you know and
so
you know I
I sort of in a way began to forgive
myself
for um
for the things that happen there in that
period of time
and um
but rehab came to an end
I got out
I still had no relationship with my
family
foreign
so back back off
Back Off to the Races you know and uh I
came to I left Texas and came to
California
um
for the first time ever and um
I went to Orange County
and the first 72 hours of being in
Orange County I got charged with
um
with
strong armed robbery in a residential
area
which is a 211
um
I will add the victim was coached
but nonetheless I ended up back in
prison within three three days of being
in California
and uh
man California is a whole new monster
this place
this this place can be
the land of opportunity
certainly in a good way but most
definitely in a bad way
this place the best of the best of the
best at being the worst come here
and I I feel like I've
met every single one of them
and
the brand of drug addict and criminal
that's out here
don't want
they don't want to get clean in fact
they're trying to they don't want
anything different they want
things
not just to stay the same but
it's like it's like there's a driving
force and everybody's just trying to
like make it to where
that that uh
negative way of living can can can be
lived
it at night and during the day you know
and I had never experienced anything
like that before so whenever I went to
prison out here
I'm around you know I'm around a bunch
of guys and
you know
previously my prison visits you know
everybody's trying to get into programs
to do this and that out here you go to
prison
and
you buy a pair of shoes
and
the drugs come in and
you raise your hand to
do violent [ __ ] so that you get blessed
with drugs and that's the name of the
game
you know
and
so it just it
anger and depression and hate and
all of this stuff like it just
it just like grew
and
and it's like it's like
you know I'm I'm from Louisiana it's
slow it's slow pace over there out here
in California
I find
I find that
90 of the time
what I'm
what I'm looking at with my own eyes is
the opposite of what it actually is and
I'll find I know that I'm going to find
that out
soon
but
in the beginning when I first got out
here I was really naive to that you know
so I found myself in a lot of situations
where
where I got
I got Bamboozled you know and
um anyway I so I did I did some prison
time and thought that I had figured out
how to you know maneuver through being
in this new
crazy place and
I get out and leave Orange County and
come to Los Angeles and
um
when I get out here to Los Angeles
I mean that was like a whole nother
like step into the dark and like
it's like a house is smoking mirrors you
know and
and it it's taken me a lot it's taken me
a long time out here to uh
to be where I'm at to be able to sit
where I'm at and know the things I know
and and understand the things I
understand
and
every day I'm reminded that I'm still
just the tip of the iceberg and
I
am now
a person that
this is my this is a way of life you
know
and
so
I get out to Los Angeles
and
I I start doing heroin and uh Crystal
and you know just indulging in drugs and
um and meeting people and forming
um warming relationships with people and
um
which was so Los Angeles essentially got
its hooks in my back and
I felt like there's nowhere else in this
world that I'd rather be and I still
feel that way I feel like I feel like
there's nowhere else I
I would really fit in anymore
um
and
so since you know
since I've been out here I've been on
the streets and
I've
I've
read I've I've seen
I
I've seen so much
death
in my life from Hurricane Katrina
between Hurricane Katrina and just
living every day in Los Angeles
that like
it's the it's so when I realized it a
couple years ago it was a really cold
realization but like I am so
desensitized to what
your normal person
would like
just be [ __ ] repulsed by or like
would be like oh my God you know oh my
God that's so that's so this so that
like
just
like
anyway to so about two years ago
um
you know heroin had been in my life
all this time but man two years ago
Fentanyl
hit the streets two and a half maybe two
and a half years ago
and of course you know
I'm an opiate addict
that's like the Mecca
I got on it
and
everybody got on it what am I talking
about everybody it seems like
I mean you can find the [ __ ] on the
ground
you know
I mean it's [ __ ] dangerous like you
can find the [ __ ]
on the train it's sitting next it's
sitting on the seats it's [ __ ]
everywhere and
I
and and everybody that I met when I
first got out here is dead
everybody except for maybe like three
people everybody's dead from from that
first wave of Fenton all that hit
if you didn't die
you're stuck here
you know and
um
I mean like just yesterday
just yesterday
I was riding the train somewhere
and I think I was going to Hollywood
and I'm looking out as we're passing a
train platform you know a stop right
before we got to Hollywood
and I look out
not one but there's two people on either
end of the
train platform
under a white sheet with the coroners
there
meaning
these two people may not have even known
each other
they were smoking in different places
that's how like that's how rampant this
[ __ ] is out here and it perpetuates so
much [ __ ] crime and
and when you start feeling the that
it's time to get more it's like
I mean I mean like damn near anything
or almost anything becomes possible like
I don't put anything past anybody and I
constantly have my guard up and I have
zero friends because everybody and I
mean everybody
foreign
a come up out for themselves
there's nobody that can be trusted
not even myself and it's and and that's
the re that's that derives straight from
the fentanyl use so
Los Angeles was already like this like
this crime holiday place and
now now that fentanyl's torn this city
up like
it is
I mean I don't even know I I there's not
even words for it like
and I'm and I'm like
and I'm like right in the middle of it
and
you know somebody asked me the other day
I was uh I was stealing in a store right
and this uh this kid that's working loss
prevention we have a standoff in the
elevator
because I'm leaving through the elevator
with all this merchandise and we have
this standoff in the elevator and
he uh
I don't press a button and he doesn't
press the button so we're just standing
in the elevator and he's like why
why do you do this
and I was like
because
[Music]
I've got
warrants and needs that need to be met
and this is the way
that I meet him just like the reason
that you go to work
and
and the kid was like um
the kid was like are
so do you do it for drugs
and I was like
yeah of course I do it for drugs
you know there's I don't I don't know of
any
I don't know anywhere that would hire me
right now
and I don't even know that I could make
it to work or that I would want to make
it to work
and
that was like
like I said that was like that was a few
days ago and um
it's had me thinking
over the past few days like
so you know my birthday's coming up my
birthday's coming up uh I'll be 32 on
November 9th and uh
and so I was thinking I was thinking
about my birthday coming up I'm 32. I'm
in my 30s now like I was thinking like
hmm uh what
what do you want what do you ruin out at
all like everything like what
at the end of all it's like what what do
you want what what kind of like are you
gonna do you want a legacy like what
what is it
and you know I'm asking myself this and
and
this is this this is this is a legacy
it's just
like the name of like the name like the
name of your show you know it's a soft
white underbelly nobody
it's a sensitive subject you know
people
everybody has a rhyme and a reason they
do things even if they don't know it and
I feel like I'm a part of something here
like even if I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is really like
and
I feel like
I feel like
I want to
I feel like
the little bit that I did get to live
of a
somewhat normal life
before all of this
never did I feel
like I was a part of something but I
feel like I'm a part of something in a
weird way and I don't plan on leaving
anytime soon I feel like I'm going to be
here and I'm okay with that and I love
it actually
Los Angeles is like groomed me into
being
one of those smoke and mirror people
and
it was uncomfortable getting here but
now that I'm here I think I'm here to
stay you know
so okay yeah cereal thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you fascinating thank you very
much have a good day good luck